am i right nice mains are always like my
inner through the spindle okay that's my
time you guys okay you get hungry
well this next panel oon has been seen
fooling around castles all over the
kingdom which comes as no surprise he's
a woman moving up for Jessica everyone
Jessica all right make some noise if
your only function in society is for
financial benefit to a lord but what do
I know I'm just a maiden wearing pants
you weren't that bad for a female
gesture you realize how insulting that
is right even though you're trying to
compliment me do you want another drink
or not
not so bad
female gesture oh come on
perhaps if you made your jokes a little
more relatable like Todd I mean they're
not going handmaidens or nothing am i
right yeah so the other fortnight I
wasn't feeling well and I called in
plague a king walks into a Tavern at
allthe I stays shut up Todd like called
in sick I get it this is [ __ ]
the middle gestures go up there and they
just make jokes about their swords for
the entire set but if I talk about
anything that's interesting to me I get
my head cut off literally the Booker
threatened me with a guillotine right I
if you just made your jokes a little
more relatable to the audience I think
it would start like brutally fighting on
my horse while oppressing women and
receiving all the benefits of male
privilege yeah those are real fingers
hey oh hey come on don't cry now yeah
why not to chat
okay let's just go back to my room start
writing jokes make things funny I guess
I can't hate myself anymore that was yes
no no hard no like maybe
no I just bought a horse